.
. . . . Hey! Das sind wir, hallo! Das ist Florentin Will, muss man sagen. Ja, völlig richtig. Und das war das Intro von Justus. Vielen Dank an Justus, der uns dieses fantastische Intro gemacht hat. Tolle Arbeit, gut gemacht, toll gemischt. Hallo Stefan, schön, dass du da bist.
Lockere Folge heute mal.
Ich bin im Urlaubsmodus.
Man merkt das.
Das sind diese zwei Tage, bevor man in den Urlaub fährt, wo man sich denkt, was muss
ich packen, hier habe ich das.
Will ich überhaupt in den Urlaub fahren?
Will ich, ist es nicht letztlich zu viel Stress, Kosten-Nutzen-Rechnung wird nochmal
hochgerechnet, aber ich bin im Halburlaub.
Wann packst du denn deinen Koffer, wenn du weißt, dass du so bald losgehst? Ich parke am Tag der Abreise. Am Tag der Abreise. Das ist mein Geheimnis, weil ich denke, ich habe immer das Problem, wenn ich dann am Abend vor der Abreise, wo ja die meisten Leute packen, habe ich immer das Problem, dass ich mir denke, naja, aber was ist, wenn ich das jetzt noch brauche? Vor allem, was ist morgen? Was passiert morgen? Morgen ist ein neuer Tag. Morgen ist ein neuer Tag. Was passiert morgen? Was passiert in der Nacht? Brauche ich Dinge, die im Koffer dann schon sind, irgendwie säuberlich eingeräumt? Zum Beispiel Zahnbürste. Kannst du nicht am Abend davor einpacken? Zwei Zahnbürsten. Weil du sie am Abend noch brauchst. Das heißt, das ist schon mal, da muss der Reissverschluss nochmal offen bleiben. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn der Reissverschluss eh offen bleibt, dann pack doch erst am nächsten Tag. Dann nehme ich das Buch mit, da lese ich heute vielleicht noch rein. Nein, der Trick ist, die Kulturtasche reinlegen zuerst, dann drumrum packen, dann die Kulturtasche, den Toilettenbeutel, dann den Toilettenbeutel. Ich bin hier nicht der Akademiker, Stefan, ich bin ein Mann aus dem Volk. Die Kulturtasche, also der Toilettensack. Der Moment, wo ich Kulturtasche gesathe, war der Moment, wo ich erwachsen wurde. Ja. Wo man merkt, okay, das ist halt das mein Leben. Ich nehme meine Kulturtasche, meine Kulturrucksack. Es gibt eine sehr limitierte Anzahl von Beuteln, muss man sagen, oder? Also in seinem Leben, man hat eigentlich nur das Federmäppchen und dann den Klosack eigentlich. Im Grunde hat man nur die Beine. Gibt es sonst noch wichtige Beutel im Leben? Naja, es gibt noch das Etui und die Kulturtasche.
Etui ist noch mal eine andere Sache.
Etui, auch so ein Wort.
Faulenzer?
Was ist das denn? Das waren diese länglichen,
diese runden, diese Röhren. Ach ja.
Ja, das war immer, nee, nee.
Ich will mal das Etui, was man feinsäuberlich
aufklappt, wo dann wirklich
nach der Farbe sortiert,
im Farbstpektrum angeordnet,
erst die Filzstifte, dann die Buntstifte, dann der Füller, Stabilo-Füller, dann die Patronen, dann Lineal, dann rechts diese Klarsichtfülle, wo man das Hausaufgaben hat, reinmachen konnte. So dass der Mobber einfach nur einmal die ganze Mappe durchbrechen muss und dann hast du alle. Hey, mein Kultur-Etui! Hey!
Etui ist eines dieser Worte, die nur für ganz spezielle Dinge verwendet werden.
Brillen-Etui.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Etuis.
Nee.
Aber es gibt kaum Etuis.
Oder sowas wie Arkaden.
Das sagt man nur für Geschäfte, die in der Reihe sind.
Aber Arkaden als solche, so diese Bögen-Reihe, kann ja mehr geben.
Etui an sich kannst du ja alles Mögliche in Etui packen. Pinsel-Etui. Aber es gibt nur ganz wenige Etuis. Das ist ein ganz wundervolles Wort. Arkaden ist ein schönes Wort, das stimmt. Aber ich habe noch keine guten Erfahrungen in Arkaden gemacht. Letzten Endes ist es dann doch eine Enttäuschung. Letzten Endes sind Arkaden doch einfach auch schäbige Einkaufszentren, oder nicht? Ja, ich glaube, es gibt die WDR-Arkaden in Köln zum Beispiel. Das stimmt, das ist wie so Arkaden-Sternchen, so ist kein wirkliches Einkaufszentrum. Ja genau, sorry. Es ist vor allem auch so ein bisschen im Frühkindlichen, weil ja das krasseste, was es ja in Deutschland nicht so gibt, aber diese Arcade, dieses Haus, in dem ganz viel Spaß ist. Und es gab es in Italien immer als Spielhölle oder Spielhalle, da bin ich mir bis heute nicht sicher. Es ist nicht wie Spasskassekasse? Es heißt Spielhalle, aber Leute, die sich darüber lustig machen, sagen MacDove oder Spasskasse, Schlepptop zum Bleistift und halt Spielhölle, oder nicht? Ist das nicht ... Ich war, keine Ahnung, ich bin ja der dritte Sohn, das heißt, ich bin der kleinste Sohn. Von 16, das wissen wir nicht. Richtig. Sagst du mal nur der dritte Sohn. Niemand weiß, was das bedeutet. Von wie vielen? Ich werde in eine Welt geboren, die primär schon von anderen strukturiert wurde. Meine gesamte Kindheit wurde mir überreicht von Eltern. Was haben deine Brüder gemacht, dass sie die Welt strukturiert haben? Nee, sie haben zum Beispiel Jösser Briffe geprägt, wie zum Beispiel... Nein, die haben T-Shirts aufgetragen. Auch? Die haben nicht die Welt geprägt. Doch, die haben die Welt geprägt. Was haben deine Brüder gemacht. Du als Einzelkind zum Beispiel, du fährst in Urlaub. Ja, da schwingt dieser Ton schon wieder mit. Nein, nein, du fährst in Urlaub und siehst in Italien diese Hallen mit den Spielautomaten und du denkst dir, oh, das sieht nach Spaß aus. Aber du hast kein Wort dafür. Ich als Bruder fahre da hin und die sagt, komm, wir gehen in die Spielhalle. Halle oder Hölle, ich weiß nicht genau. Und dann habe ich schon die Struktur dafür, dass ich daheim bin.
Bis heute weiß ich aber nicht genau, ob es Hölle oder Halle geht.
Hölle ist doch so die Eltern, die Eltern sagen doch Hölle, oder nicht?
Warum sollte man das sagen, Spielhölle? Das ist ein Oxymoron.
Ja, keine Ahnung, man ist ja so ein bisschen rebellisch, so Antikirche und so.
Scheiß Josef und so, man ist da ja total drin. Gehen Spielautomaten und Kirche nicht einher? Nee, also mein Lieblingsspielautomat war Monkey Ball. Und da hattest du statt einem Joystick eine Banane, aber halt eine Plastikbanane. Und allein das hat mich schon so gecatcht, dass du so eine Banane hast und an diesen Ball steuern musst, bin immer runtergefallen, aber das fand ich immer gut.
Aber da weiß man nicht genau, was das ist.
Und Etui ist so ähnlich, man könnte ja noch viel mehr Dinge Etui nennen,
aber da kann man eine neue Liste anlegen von Worten, Bezeichnungen,
die nur für ganz bestimmte Dinge benutzt werden.
Ja, also Ball, damit kannst du ganz viele Dinge bezeichnen. Eigentlich sind die meisten Dinge nur mit dem Wort benutzt, das es hat. Nee, also wie wir es zum Beispiel mal hatten mit dem Wort rassig. Rassig wird nur für eine Verwendung benutzt, und zwar für lateinamerikanische Frauen. Eine rassige Latina. So, und dieses sehr, sehr merkwürdige Wort rassig wird sonst, du würdest nicht sagen, ein rassiger Däne. Das versteht niemand. Das ist allein ein Wort, um die Attribute einer lateinamerikanischen Frau zu beschreiben. Jeder weiss, was damit gemeint ist, aber das ist so ein Wort, das für sonst nichts verwendet wird. Weißt du, was da hilft? Die Google-Bildersuche. Ah, ich weiss nicht. Rassig. Familienfilter aus, natürlich. Rassig. Der Spaß geht los, der Familienfilter. Latina, Latina, Latina, Latina, Latina, Latina, Latina, Meme, Latina, Latino. Aber mach mal Etui. Mercedes, Mercedes SUV. Ich glaube, Etui ist ganz klar. Sagt man nicht einfach Etui auch? Ich habe immer Etui gesagt. Etui klingt wie so ein Pokémon, so ein drittes Edition Pokémon. Klassisch, Bild eins, Etui, Etui, Etui, Faulenzer, Brillenetui. Ja, Brillenetui, aber ansonsten nichts. Und ein Nagelset. Genau, Nageletui, da hatte ich nämlich auch mal eins. Maniküretui. Da hatte ich nämlich auch mal eins, aber es ist so, das verwendet man nicht für so viele Sachen.
Ja, Kulturtasche verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz. Für Kultur schwingt der da nicht mit. Naja, Kulturare heißt ja Pflegen ursprünglich. Ja, gut, alles klar. Dann kommt das da, ja, Kulturbeutel. Boah, mein ganzes Zeug liegt hier drüben. Kurze Hosenzeit ist ja schrecklich, weil ich habe ja Joggingkurze Hosen und die Sonne dafür, dass alles konstant rausfällt. Ja, vor allem, ich habe mir jetzt in Berlin, gibt es Coop und mit Coop kannst du dir einen Roller leihen, einen Elektroroller in Berlin. Und dann hatte ich diese kurze Jogginghose an und die ganze Zeit die Angst, dass mir einfach alles, wie wenn man das kennt aus Sci-Fi-Filmen, wenn man die Gegner hinten loswerden will, dass man kurz den Müll abwirkt und die Tifiter hinter einem zerstört werden, hatte ich kurz die Angst, dass hinter mir einfach Berlin zerstört wird, weil erst mein iPhone rausfliegt, dann die Airpods, dann das Portemonnaie und so weiter. Aber ich habe nichts verloren dann doch. Ich bin nur die ganze Zeit mit Warnblinker gefahren, weil ich die Knöpfe nicht ganz verstanden habe. Achtmal gehupt und die konntiert mich mit Warnblinker oder mit Linksblinken. Immer Hupe und Gas geben vertauscht, das ist dann immer an der Ampel schwierig. Aber mir ist es wirklich immer so, ich setze mich irgendwo hin und ich stehe auf und ich schaue zurück auf auch ein Brachland an benutzten Taschentüchern, Taschenkugparken, Krimeln, Beutel, iPod, iPhone, alles liegt da. Wirklich wie so eine Schlange, die sich gehäutet hat, liegt da so ein bisschen meine Umrisse, Körperumrisse auf dem Sitz in irgendwelchen Zeugen, das mir aus der Tasche gefallen ist. Sehr unangenehm. Warum, was kann man dagegen tun? Tiefe Taschen. Man muss eigentlich nach tiefen Taschen shoppen. Naja, ich glaube, es liegt eher daran, wie senkrecht die Tasche ist. Es gibt ja so richtige Schlauchtaschen, so Cargo-Shorts, die sind ja wirklich senkrecht zum Boden. Das kann man nicht so sagen. Das ist eine sehr pauschale Aussage. Naja, die auf den Beinen sind. Man weiss nicht genau, aber du hast recht, der Winkel ist entscheidend und die Tiefe der Taschen, weil dann ist der Winkel fast egal. Dann ist der Winkel fast egal, weil dann kommt die Gravitation hinzu und dann ist es auch egal. Ich habe schon, sag ich mal, recht ausladenden Hüftschwung beim Laufen. Das stimmt. Da werden schon Kräfte mobilisiert in den Taschen. Da glaube ich, könnte ich auch die längste Tasche überwinden, wenn der Winkel stimmt. Das stimmt. Ich gehe eher so Pinguin-Style, also wenn man sich ein Metronom vorstellt, was man auf sich zubewegt. So gehe ich ungefähr. Man schwingt nach links und rechts. Du hast auffallend wenig Armbewegung beim Laufen. Das stimmt. Und du hast auffallend viel Rotation. Also du bist nicht das Metronom, du drehst dich quasi um dich selber. Ich bin die Disco-Kugel. Ja, also wenn rassige Frauen auf die Tanzlöche gehen, weil ihr Song kommt, weil Mambo No. 5 kommt oder damals Mambo No. 4 noch. Und du bist so ein bisschen, du gehst dann auch so, das ist so ein Einladen in den Hüftschung. Kannst du dich noch erinnern an die Man in Black Cartoon Serie? Nein, ich habe noch nie davon gehört sogar. Weil die hatten ein ultra geiles Intro, also bahnbrechend geil, also leben die ganz nicht. man in black, so und die hatten einfach ein mega geiles, super cooles Intro und in den ersten Frames waren die beiden, also ich glaube, das waren nicht genau die Figuren aus den Filmen, aber auch wieder ein schwarzer und ein weisser und die laufen so am Anfang und die bewegen ihre Schultern so, wie man es in Comicserien noch kaum gesehen hat. Ah, und das hat mir so in den Kopf gebracht. So will ich gehen. Dass ich da immer wieder dachte, so will ich gehen eines Tages. Wenn ich Serien gucke, bin ich oft dann drin. Ich bin so drin, dass ich oft, kurz damit darüber nachdenke, diesen Beruf ausüben zu wollen. Das geht mir auch oft so, ja. Das geht mir dann so, und ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde auch dann so melancholisch. Jetzt zum Beispiel will ich mit Rauchen anfangen, weil ich mal wieder in den Newsroom gucke und Will Macaboy irgendwann immer so, auch
bei House of Cards habe ich das schon so empfunden,
du hast einfach teilweise, oder bei True Detective,
du hast einfach so sehr schöne Rauch-Szenen.
Vor allem bist du mit dem Mikrofon
so nah an der Zigarette, dass du dieses
Knistern hast. Und ich denke mir,
ja gut, dann fange ich halt an zu rauchen, dann ist es jetzt halt so,
dann ist es um mich geschehen, okay.
Und irgendwie, ich embrace dieses
Filmbild immer so,
dass ich dann auch so sein will. Vor allem, die Zigarette ist ja der Traum für jeden Schauspieler, weil das größte Problem eines jeden Schauspielers immer ist, was mache ich mit den Händen? Das kann man vor allem im Theater beobachten. Das ein guter Schauspieler wirkt so, als hätte er keine Hände, weil sie nicht auffallen. Deswegen hast du in jedem Stück meistens so einen Totenkopf in der Hand. Da hände die drunter gefallen. Und ja, genau, deswegen, ich glaube, das ist wirklich so, der Hamden-Toten-Kopf. Der Hamden-Toten-Kopf. Weil man was in der Hand haben muss. Und das ist ja genial, wenn du rauchen kannst, weil du immer einfach cool aussiehst und du hast beide Hände irgendwie bedient, weil die andere Hand ist dann eher lowkey und die andere ist einfach cool. Es funktioniert einfach deswegen so gut. Worauf ich hinaus wollte, und deswegen, glaube ich, gewöhne ich mir auch manchmal den Gang meiner Lieblingsfigur an in dieser Serie. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich dann eher in meinem Kopf ist, oder wenn jemand die gleiche Serie guckt, ihm auffällt, was ist denn bei ihm, warum geht er denn genau wie Figur XY aus meiner Lieblingsserie gerade? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, man will dann, man identifiziert sich so sehr mit den Figuren, dass man dann so sein will wie die. Das wäre so ein klassischer Sherlock-Holmes-Moment, wenn er dann das Opfer auf der Überwachungskamera sieht, laufend, und dann sieht man genau so, ah, so wie der läuft, schaut er wohl gerade Kimmy Schmidt. Klassischer Kimmy Schmidt-Gang. Was guckst du gerade so? Für mich mal, was machst du gerade so? Ich muss auch sagen, wir sehen uns mittlerweile noch einmal die Woche. Auf Netflix gibt es jetzt von Vox, die machen so eine, also nicht die, die, nicht Vox. Also auf Netflix gibt es von Dreisert jetzt, was für eine Serie? Es gibt ja einmal Fox, meine ich nicht. Dann gibt es den deutschen Sender Vox, den meine ich auch nicht. Dann gibt es den YouTube-Kanal Vox, den meinst du?
Ja, der so Erklärvideos macht.
Und da gibt es auch eine Serie auf Netflix,
die immer so tatsächlich unterschiedlich lange Videos machen.
Explained, genau. Die schaue ich gerade an, sehr gut.
Ich habe nur eine Folge gesehen über K-Pop.
Ich habe die nicht bewusst angeklickt, aber es war sehr spannend.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und da ging es jetzt auch um das Ausrufezeichen zum Beispiel, die Geschichte des Ausrufezeichens.
Wie haben Leute da vorgesprochen, vor der Erfindung des Ausrufezeichens? Ja, das wurde irgendwann erfunden. Die Frage ist dann, wenn du zu so klassischen Stoff, wie das Beispiel, das genannt wurde, ist Beowulf, so diese klassische germanische Sage, glaube ich, und die veröffentlicht du jetzt. Und die hatten halt einfach keine Ausrufezeichen. Fügst du jetzt im Nachhinein noch Ausrufezeichen hinzu, so wie man es wahrscheinlich verwendet hätte, wenn man Ausrufezeichen gehabt hätte oder nicht? Weil ansonsten wirken manche Sachen halt schon sarkastisch, wenn du halt einfach schreibst, hey Lothgar, willst du auf den nächsten Beutezug und der andere sagt, ja klar, Megabock, Punkt. Das wirkt aus heutiger Perspektive halt so, dass du denkst, Lothar hatte nicht wirklich Bock.
Kurze Frage, wir wissen ja, dass wir das Ausrufezeichen haben, wir ja ewig lange darüber gesprochen, dass wir das dann doch hinzufügen wollten. Das Wort Mega, ist das jetzt neu? Hatten wir uns darauf verständigt? Ich glaube nicht, dass sie Mega hatten, sie hatten Ultra, Hyper, aber Mega nicht. Wir müssen Mega eigentlich schon noch einfügen. Dann auf Seite 23 Voll cool, Lodga.
Da habe ich mich auch gefragt, ist das Ihr Ernst oder haben Sie einen Tippfehler oder? Naja, Sie haben damals geschrieben gediegen, aber ich dachte, man übersetzt das in voll cool. Ich habe Lulz auch noch reingeschrieben und einmal da gibt es eine Romantikszene, da dachte ich, passt dieser Emoji mit den Herzaugen eigentlich ganz gut rein. Von daher eigentlich kann genau so raus. Vor allem ist es auch interessant, dass man da irgendwann drei Ausrufezeichen nacheinander macht. Oh ja. Und dann gibt es auch ein Schritt, muss man sagen. Und dann gab es irgend so einen Werbetypen in den 60er Jahren oder so, der wollte ein neues Werbezeichen erfinden. It's toasted. Und der in Tarot bang und zwar Ausrufezeichen und Fragezeichen kombiniert. Heute verwendet man das ja gerne für ausgerufene Fragen, wie ... Ist das dein Ernst? Genau, und dann machen wir Fragezeichen, Ausrufezeichen. Ja, Fragezeichen, Ausrufezeichen. Und der wollte das aber kombinieren, hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Und es gibt da tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe an vergessenen Satzzeichen, die irgendwann mal eingeführt werden sollen. Wie das Ironiesatzzeichen zum Beispiel, was natürlich Quatsch ist. Aber das wollte auch mal jemand einführen. Oh, ganz spannend. Ganz spannend. Ich dachte erst, ich hasse Leute, die das machen. Mittlerweile kann ich es verstehen. Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Fragezeichen. Ja, naja, finde ich, muss schon sein. Ja, muss schon sein. Weil es ist ja trotzdem noch eine Frage. Oder ist das denn trotzdem noch eine Frage? Ja, wenn du zum Beispiel sowas schreibst wie... Ich glaube, wenn man es so zögert, wenn man so ein bisschen nachfragt, also langsamer und es so quasi, es hat diesen Flair von drei Punkten, aber es ist doch noch eine Frage, oder? Naja, es muss schon mit einer Auslassung zu tun haben. Also wenn du sagst, du fährst doch nächstes Jahr in den Urlaub nach. Und das würde ich formulieren mit Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Fragezeichen,
weil da hat jemand was ausgelassen, die Frage bleibt aber trotzdem als Zeugen stehen.
Was keinen Sinn macht, ist Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Ausrufezeichen.
Was Till Schweiger gerne macht in seinen wütenden Hass-Mails.
Nee, das schliesst dich aus. Du kannst nicht zögern und ausrufen gleichzeitig.
Es sei denn, dir fällt das Wort nicht richtig ein.
Was aber bei Facebook keinen Sinn macht.
Auf, nach!
Sch, ach, fuck. Sparta. Sparta. Auf nach Sparta. Hieß das damals auch schon Sparta? Ja. Oder hieß der Sparta oder sowas? Gibt's ja manchmal. Wir haben letzte Woche eine tolle neue Rubrik angefangen, und zwar haben wir gesagt, wir schreiben jetzt zusammen ein Drehbuch. Wir hatten nämlich letzte Woche eine tolle Geschichte an, Florentin, nochmal vielen Dank dafür an der Stelle. Ja, gerne. Und zwar haben wir gesagt, das ist nämlich eigentlich der perfekte Filmanfang. Und zwar, Kinder, ich lese es vor, denn ich habe es als Drehbuch geschrieben. Und wir hatten nämlich die Idee, dass wir jede Folge eine Minute weiter in diesem Drehbuch denken. So, letzte Woche haben wir angefangen und das haben wir bislang.
Das können wir jetzt aber nicht jede Woche vorlesen, weil dann werden
die Folgen immer länger und das kann wirklich niemanden
wollen. So, wir haben bis jetzt aber noch keinen Dialog,
wir haben nur State Directions.
Wir haben noch keinen Dialog, wir haben
nicht immer einen Anfang. Was würdest du schätzen,
auf welcher Seite fängt der erste Dialog an?
Wir haben keine Titelseite, das ist auch
naja,
Fade-In.
Exterior, Ballsplatz, Tag.
Kinder spielen Fussball.
Jetzt wusste ich nicht genau, wie ich weitermachen sollte, weil wir wissen das Genre noch nicht.
Wir wissen das Genre noch nicht, wir wissen das Thema nicht.
Heißt, ich habe mir so ein bisschen rumgeschwurbelt.
Sie haben eine gute Zeit, die Kinder.
Keine Sorgen, keine Pflichten, keine Verantwortung.
Sie schreien über den Lärm der vierspurigen Hauptstrasse, die unweit neben dem Beuysplatz entlang führt. Darüber Main Titles. Wie Main Titles? Was steht da? Die Main Titles. Ja, was? Die Credits. Ja, was dann? Erstmal die Credits. Wie, erst mal die Credits? Wie in einem coolen Film damals, wo immer unten erst die Namen kamen. Hatten wir letzte Woche gesagt, du könntest uns nicht mehr in Frage stellen. Sorry, es ist eingeloggt, das ist jetzt so. Also das ist wieder ein ganz gross Stefan Tietze über mehrere Sekunden bildfüllend. Ja, und David Fincher halt, alle, die da noch so mitmachen werden. Plötzlich fliegt der Ball über den Hohenzauen, direkt auf die vielbefahrene Straße. Ein Auto weicht hupend aus, der Ball kommt inmitten zweier Fahrstreifen zum Stehen. Der Junge, der offenbar in der Reihe ist, den Ball zu holen, macht sie auf den Weg. Er wartet am Straßenrand auf den optimalen Zeitpunkt. Erstmal keine Chance, zu viele Autos. Doch gerade als sich eine Lücke auftut und er sich in Richtung Ball aufmachen will, hält ein Sportwagen neben dem Ball an. Wir erkennen den Fahrer nicht, die Tür geht auf, der Junge schaut zum Auto, eine Hand greift aus dem Auto nach dem Ball, der Unbekannte nimmt den Ball zu sich ins Auto, schließt die Tür und fährt weg. Das ist unsere erste Filmminute.
Unsere allererste Filmminute.
Heute ist die Frage, wie geht's weiter?
Haben wir noch einen enttäuschten Shot des Kindes, oder nicht?
Es ist die Frage, wir dachten letzte Woche, dass wir bei dem Autofahrer bleiben.
Ich kann aber verstehen, dass man sich als Regisseur noch mal dazu entscheidet.
Ist letztlich eine inszenatorische Frage.
Aber wir lassen uns noch mal den Jungen, der Junge,
oder die Jungs, die Fussballjungs schauen enttäuscht hinterher, enttäuscht und perplex. So, und jetzt haben wir gesagt, wir folgen dem Autofahrer nach Hause. Aber ist ja nicht die Idee dieser ganzen Szene, dass man denkt, es würde bei den Kindern weitergehen. Ja, schon. Dann muss man bei den Kindern aber, glaube ich, noch mehr aufbauen. Das ist eher so eine Freistoßsituation, das unbeliebte Kind, Freistoß, alle gucken. Ja, aber in kurz, so was kannst du ja knackig in zwölf Sekunden erzählen. Irgendwie so das Kind, das als einziges keine Schuhe dabei hat oder sowas, weil es sich keine Schuhe leisten kann. Wo spielt das eigentlich? Oh, Jakob, Jakob. Und dann sagt der Freistoß und dann macht Jakob den Freistoß und man denkt, oh, jetzt ist der Außenseiter schafft es endlich, aber nein, der Ball fliegt über den Zaun, alle, ah, Jakob, Jakob, jetzt musst du ihn du auch holen, er muss über den Zaun klettern, man denkt sich, das ist die Hauptfigur, das ist die Hauptfigur Jakob, der nichts hinkriegt und dann soll er auch noch auf die Strasse jetzt und dann aber ein rettender Samariter, er öffnet die Tür, du denkst, ja, endlich hat Jakob mal einen kleinen Funken Glück in seinem Leben, greift zum Ball, nein, wieder nicht, er zieht den Ball in das Auto und er fährt weg und man denkt sich, welches Abenteuer erleben wir jetzt mit Jakob, Jakob kehrt mit leeren Händen zurück, Jakob, Jakob und dann, Cut, vibrierender Innenraum eines Autos, wir sehen den Ball auf dem Beifahrersitz. Ich habe das Gefühl, er telefoniert. Ich habe das Gefühl, er telefoniert. Hast du das auch gerade? Gerade als du bei ihm warst, bei dem Mann, dachte ich mir, der telefoniert doch gerade mit irgendwem. Wütend, mit dem Job. Oder nicht? Da müssen wir jetzt schon Dialog machen. Dialog ist schwer. Lass uns doch lieber noch mal so Coen Brothers-eske vier Minuten Interior Auto. Der Ball ist ja auf jeden Fall auch dem Beifahrersitz gelegt. Erst mal dachte ich mir, ich habe die ganze Zeit im Kopf gehabt, dass wir in so einer brasilianischen Favela sind. Aber ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen irrational, weil du halt von deiner, von Ebersberg gesprochen hast. Ja, ich würde vor allem sagen, dass man da Diebstahl erwarten würde, dass man da um jeden Basel... Ich glaube, wenn du so eine deutsche Vorstadt machst, dann fällt es eher aus dem Spektrum, dass jetzt jemand nicht mehr fällt. Nee, voll. Ich habe das die ganze Zeit nur im Kopf gehabt. Das ist aber nicht der Out, wo wir spielen lassen wollen. Was ist das für eine Hauptfigur? Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, er hat ich würde sagen, er hat einen Anzug an. Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Ja? Naja, ich glaube, er kommt gerade vom Job. Ich glaube, er ist schon mit Sportwagen also irgendwie sowas BMW Z Z4-iges. Aber der Krawattenknoten ist so gelöst und der erste Knopf ist aufgemacht. Ja, vielleicht so ein Kaffeefleck am Ärmel oder so? Ja, vielleicht. Oder vielleicht ein Nabel im Gesicht, man weiß es nicht. Irgendwie ein blauer Fleck. Lustiger Hut auf vielleicht? Nee, nee, nee. Ich weiß nicht, ob wirklich so drieblicher geschrieben wäre. Natürlich nicht. Das ist doch die Idee. Hut auf oder eher so einen kahlen Punkt am Hinterkopf. Die besten Jahre hinter sich. Wir erzählen so eine Walter-White-Story nehme ich an, oder? Er wurde gerade gefeuert, er muss jetzt zur Frau, muss sagen, dass er gescheitert ist, aber um nicht in die Arbeitslosigkeit abzudriften, macht er dann Verkauf Drogen oder macht Kinderporns oder sowas in der Richtung. Das ist dann halt Akt zwei, aber Akt zwei. Könnte man das machen? Breaking Bad mit Kinderporn? Ich glaube, wir nähern uns lieber von der Frage, was liegt noch auf dem Beifahrersitz neben dem Ball? Ja, okay. Der Detonator einer Bombe. Der selbstgebaute Knopf. Oder der erste Plottwist, auf Seite eins noch, liegt noch ein Ball da. Ist das nicht der erste? Das ganze Auto ist voller Bälle. Das finde ich lustig. Ist es vielleicht nicht der erste Ball, den er mitgenommen hat? Ja. Ich würde es nicht übertreiben, aber liegen da schon zwei andere Bälle? Aber dann stelle ich mir vor, dass man den Ball sieht auf dem Beifahrersitz und dann Schwenk auf den Rücksitz und da ist alles für eine Bälle. Achso, sorry, kurz. Oder Leiche halt, je nachdem. Aber warum sammelt denn lauter Fussballbälle auf? Ja, das ist die Frage, die wir uns auf Seite 15 stellen müssen dann. Also okay, ich würde sagen, ich würde schon sagen, Telefonat, das ist klar, er hat seinen Job verloren, Anzug, Karla Hinterkopf auf jeden Fall, also er graut schon langsam aus ein bisschen, hat die besten Jahre hinter sich und hat mehrere Bälle auf dem Beifahrersitz. Das ist die zweite Video des Films. Wenn er mehrere Bälle auf dem Beifahrersitz hat, dann kannst du das nicht inszenieren. Weil dann siehst du direkt, oh, ganz viele Bälle auf dem Beifahrersitz. Wenn du erst einen auf dem Beifahrersitz siehst und dann den Schwenk machst, dann kannst du den so, ganz viele Bälle im Auto. Ja. So, er fährt, man kann den Erinnern so, dass die so alle so vibrieren. Was ist das für ein Autofahrer? Ist er so ein hupender Autofahrer, ein wütender Autofahrer, oder bleibt er ruhig? Weil gerade so seine Reaktion war ja relativ, es war ja, er hat nicht dabei geflucht, er war nicht aufbrausend, er hat das sehr gelassen gemacht. Er fährt auf eine gelbe Ampel zu und dann? Ja genau, was macht er dann? Er gibt nochmal Gas. Und was ist auf dem Radio? Leute, wir wissen nichts über unsere Aufstehen. Geschmackvolles Hörspiel. Ja, es läuft ein Hörspiel nicht. So Thomas Mann Hörspiel. Ja, oder so Rufus Beck, der was vorliest.
Finde ich gut. Ich meine, ja. Ja, oder halt, wenn er so ein gestresster Typ ist, dann irgendwie so Wahlgesänge oder so. Aber er ist halt mega wütend, cholerisch brüllt und nebenbei die ganze Zeit diese Wahlgesänge. Und dieses Alles ist gut. Er ist nicht cholerisch, oder? Ich finde es geil, wenn er abgeschlossen hat. Also wenn du gefeuert wirst und dann halt nicht sauer wirst und wütend nach Hause fährst, sondern die gefährlichen Männer dann sind ja die, die dann ruhig bleiben und sagen, okay, alles klar. Dann darf er aber auch nicht telefonieren eigentlich, oder? Oder was telefoniert er? Nur erfahren, dass wir, vielleicht knüpft er gerade was, nur erfahren, dass er seinen Job verloren hat. Vielleicht knüpft er seine Hausratsversicherung, ich weiß es nicht. Aber kann man das nicht erzählen, dass er irgendwie diese klassische Papierbox auf dem Beifahrersitz hat? So mit Bild von der Familie. Dann kannst du auch direkt die Familie Vorschade und so von wegen, wie erzähl ich's denen. Sehr gut, haben wir es. Und dann vielleicht kommt er zur Familie und er lügt. Und die Frau fragt, ja Schatz, wie warst du auf Arbeit? Und dann kurzen Moment, ein Beat und er sagt, alles ganz normal, alles wunderbar. What? So, und dann wissen wir plötzlich, Moment, warum lügt er sich an? Warum lügt er sich an? Was hat er jetzt vor mir gestern? Das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor Breaking Bad, aber es ist geil, ich habe es, ich bin schon im Kino. Und dann fragt sie, wo Breaking Bad immer lief, Schatz, wie geht's, ja, alles in Ordnung. Und dann irgendwie im Laufe des, er versteckt dann noch so den Karton oder so, dass sie es nicht mitbekommt. Und die Bälle, was machen wir denn? Ja, die Bälle, aber das ist auch was für Minute drei. Was machen wir denn? Sich selbst schwer machen. Was machen wir mit diesem Alien, der noch im Kofferraum hat? Und was machen wir mit dem Minotaurus? Was machen wir noch damit? Was machen wir mit dem Meteor, der langsam auf die ... Das kannst du ja noch einbauen auf der ersten Seite. Ein Meteorit nähert sich der Erde und es kommt nie wieder vor im ganzen Skript. Das war die beste Stelle bei Two and a Half Men. Eine furchtbare Serie eigentlich, wenn man erwachsener wird. Als Kind habe ich mich darüber sehr gefreut. Gefreut? Ich habe mich jeden Dienstagabend auf den Comedy-Dienstag bei ProSieben gefreut. Und die beste Szene, wo ich immer darüber lachen muss, ist, wie er versucht, ein Buch zu schreiben. Und jeden Versuch und jeden Entwurf des Buches anfängt mit Ein greller Blitz am Himmel, ein flammender Meteor stürzt zur Erde. Ein greller Blitz, Achtung, ein greller Blitz am Himmel. Das kommt am Ende, das würde ich sagen, ist dann für Wer hat den Ball gestohlen, Teil zwei kommt dann. Ja, oder halt so dann so nach den Credits nochmal als Bonusszene so. Foreshadowing. Ich dachte mir, wann kommt der erste Marvel-Film, der nicht als solcher angeteast wird? Also, der aussieht wie ein Film, wo man so reingeht und plötzlich kommt raus, ah, das ist der neue Tor zum Beispiel. Also, weil jetzt dachte ich mir, es ging dann irgendwie, neulich kam so eine Werbung im Kino für so einen neuen Jaws-artigen Film, wo so ein grosser Hai rumschwimmt. Was, wenn dann irgendwann man im Kino sitzt und guckt sich so einen neuen Jaws-artigen Film an, wo ein Hai rumschwimmt und plötzlich kommt Aquaman und hetzt den Hai auf einen Kleinstadt, wo gerade eine Bar eröffnet wurde oder sowas. Das fände ich interessant. Das ist ja die Frage, ob sowas noch funktioniert, mit der heutigen Marketing. Aber dann würden doch alle erst recht reingehen, weil alle sagen, Alter, der Film, in dem ich gestern war, stellt sich raus, war nicht ein weiterer Jaws-Film, war der neue Aquaman. Ja, aber dann, du kannst ja nicht mit einer Überraschung werben, weil dann ist es ja keine Überraschung. Mund zu Mund. Mund zu Ohr vielleicht eher, oder? Stimmt, warum heißt es Mund zu Mund Propaganda? Warum redest du in meinem Mund? Ich habe gestern diesen geilen Film gesehen. Ganz so heißes wirklich, eisst es nicht Mund zu Mund PropagandaPropaganda? Ich glaube, es heißt nur Mund-Propaganda. Mund-Propaganda. Aber das wäre weird. Das wäre sehr merkwürdig, ja. Mund-zu-Schuh-Propaganda. Es funktioniert nicht. Niemand schaut unseren Film an. Naja. Ist ja die Frage, ne? Also, ich glaube, das beste Beispiel für so eine Art von Film ist ja From Dusk Till Dawn. Ja, genau. Weiß nicht, ob man das heute noch so machen könnte. Vielleicht eher so als Indie-Projekt dann, was nebenbei. Ja, okay. Aber lass uns doch genau diesen Film schreiben. Wir schreiben ja gerade einen Film, Stefan. Naja. Wir können ja auf Seite 40 dann nochmal irgendwie Ant-Man auftauchen lassen. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, fühlt es sich noch nicht so richtig wie ein Film an. Aber okay, ich lasse mich überzeugen. Kann ja auch eine Serie werden, oder halt ein GIF, je nachdem. Also man muss ja die Form, muss sich ja finden erst durch den den Inhalt. Wenn The Medium The Message ist, haben GIFs dann nicht von vornherein einen schweren Stand? Ja, stimmt schon. Ist The Medium The Message? Ja, halt schon, aber auch irgendwo nicht. Flote Willmann, glaube ich. Und morgen im Dreisatt-Kulturtalk. Ja, The Medium ist irgendwo The Message, aber irgendwo ... Aber irgendwo halt, weil es sind halt schon zwei verschiedene Sachen. Und den Will kommentiert. Dankeschön. Falls du gefragt hast, was ich gerade schaue, Serienempfehlung. Pew, pew! Und zwar eine Serie, die niemand kennt, verächtlicherweise, weil sie ist grossartig. sie ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Sopranos. Und zwar The Simpsons. Ja? Niemand hat geklopft. Was war das denn gerade? Niemand hat geklopft. Hat gerade ein Klopfen gehört. Das war jetzt der beste Schulgag, wenn man auf dem Tisch geklopft hat und dann, wer ist denn da? Und niemand kommt rein und die Klasse sagt, wer, wer ist denn da? Und das ging dann in zehn Minuten so. Oh, dich gefolgt vom anderen besten Schulgag, wenn du jemandem links auf die Schulter klopfst. Ja, aber eigentlich rechts bist. Geil, ich war so paranoid, dass ich manchmal, wenn mir jemand links auf die Schulter geklopft habe, ich bewusst nach rechts geguckt habe, was halt blöd ist, wenn wirklich jemand links neben dir steht. Weil dann denkt man sich, was bist du für ein Trottel. Irgendwann bist du zum Trottel erzogen. Tolle Serie, auf Sky zu sehen, Olive Kitteridge. Grossartig, mit der fantastischen Frances McDormand, kennt man aus Two Billboards, Outside Louis, Missouri. Grossartige Serie, nur vier Folgen. Outside was? Louis, Missouri, Lewis Missouri, Lewin. Ebbing. Ebbing. Ebbing Missouri. Grossartig, Olive Kitteridge, schaut's euch an, auf Sky sehr ernst, sehr fantastisch, sehr einnahmend, grossartig. Cool. Das freut mich. Toll. Was hab ich zu empfehlen? Schaut mal nochmal The Newsroom. Weißt du, ich hab auch keinen Bock, mich immer auf neue Sachen zu fokussieren. Warum sind wir jetzt eher... Ich schaue schon wieder in The Newsroom. Mega Serie. Grossartig und dann, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, Nathan For You. Fantastische Reality-Comedy-Serie. Unfassbar lustig, unglaublich genial. Und einfach anschauen kann man sich auf iTunes holen. Auf YouTube gibt es auch ganz viele Clips Nathan For You. Auch von der gleichen Produktionsfirma, die auch alles von Adult Swim irgendwie gefühlt macht. The Eric Andre Show, Tim & Eric. Absolutely. Heißen die. Und die haben auch ... Ich weiß nicht, ob die so heißen, aber das kommt nach jeder Folge immer. Die heißen Absolutely. Genau, das ist die Absolutely Productions. Ja, sehr zu empfehlen. Machen nur gutes Zeug, wirklich, muss man sagen. So, wir müssen leider durch die Themen, die wir uns aus alten Wochen weitergeschleppt haben, denn es hat auch noch mal eine kleine Neuerung gegeben in unserer WC-End-Storyline. Tatsächlich stimmt, aber nicht direkt von der Haupt-Storyline, oder? Wir sind schon in der Nebenquest, wir sind schon in der, soll ich das wirklich machen für 30 Goldstücke-Quest. Ein Hörer von uns, Moritz, hat geschrieben, hallo ihr beiden, erstmal vielen, vielen Dank für den geilen Content, den ihr seit Jahren abliefert. Ihr macht jetzt die gute Arbeit, Moritz Kuro. Ihr betrefft euch immer wieder selbst. Vielen Dank, Moritz. Okay. Ja. Das war die... Ja. Ich habe versucht, bei SC Johnson mehr zum Schwan, ein Entenproblem herauszufinden, was ich euch nicht vorenthalten möchte. Ganz kurz, Moritz hat direkt auch an WC Ente Kundensupport geschrieben. Er hat auch an St. Johnson geschrieben. Vielen Dank dafür. Kleine Bitte an alle Zuhörer. Ja, lass das. Bitte macht das nicht, übertreibt es nicht, weil vor allem die, irgendwann checken die, dass sie einfach verarscht werden. Und generell finde ich das nicht so cool, weil es dann auch nicht mehr lustig wird. Und auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube so ein, zwei Mails kann man mal schreiben, aber wenn die jetzt 30 Spaß-Mails bekommen, ist es, hört es irgendwann auf, dass sie vor sein. Dann ist es wirklich nervig. Schreibt bitte nichts mehr. Er hat geschrieben, ich bin mit ihrem Produkt WC-Interaktiv-Gel sehr zufrieden, jedoch ist mir nun im Rahmen meines Lehramtsstudiums aufgefallen, dass ihr Produkt nicht nur falsch benannt ist, sondern auch bereits Kinder in die Irre führt. Unter einer Ente verstehen die meisten Deutschen die in Deutschland vorkommende Stockente. Diese haben jedoch einen Hals, welcher in keinster Weise Ähnlichkeit mit ihrem Produkt hat. Ihre Produktverpackung erinnert vielmehr dem Hals eines Schwans. Cygnini. Ist es von ihrer Seite geplant, den Namen ihres Produktes an der Realität in der freien Wildbahn anzupassen, oder zumindest die Kunden darauf hinzuweisen, dass die Bezeichnung irreführend ist. Ich bin auf Ihre Antwort sehr gespannt. Und man muss sagen, ich glaube, die langsam merken sie, dass was falsch läuft. Aber das finde ich erstmal eine sehr gute Mail, auch weil er einen ganz anderen Ansatz genommen hat, als wir mit seinem Lehrer-Dasein. Und ich finde es gut, dass er beschreibt, dass dieses Produkt nicht nur falsch ist, sondern auch Schaden anrichtet. Dass Kinder in ganz Deutschland verwirrt sind, weil sie nicht wissen, wie eine Ente aussieht. Ich finde, die lehnen sich jetzt, aber ihr seid die Juroren. Ich glaube, die lehnen sich ein bisschen weit aus dem Fenster jetzt. Sehr geehrter Herr, vielen Dank für Ihre Anfrage. Gerne nehmen wir uns Ihres Anliegens an. Das Produkt gibt es inzwischen fast 40 Jahre. Bis jetzt hat sich niemand in die Irre führen lassen. Woher wollt ihr das denn wissen? Woher wollt ihr das denn wissen? Vielleicht Marktforschung? Ferner würden wir ihnen empfehlen, sich auf die wichtigen Dinge ihres Studiums zu konzentrieren. Studium bedeutet übrigens eifrige Bemühungen und nicht sinnentleertes Lustwandeln. Holy Crap! What the fighter! Tja! Okay, ich... Studium bedeutet übrigens eifrige Bemühungen und nicht sinnentleertes Lustwandeln. Was? Wenn Sie weitere Fragen haben oder weitere Informationen bemerken, konntieren Sie uns bitte mit freierlichen Grüßen, Markus Kopp. Es ist übrigens der gleiche, der uns auch geschrieben hat. Ich glaube, es nervt die. Ja, ich glaube, die haben es auch verstanden irgendwann. Ich frag mich wirklich, ob sie es verstanden haben, dass es von uns kommt oder dass sie zusammenhängen. Ich glaube aber aus der Mail nicht, weil also ich meine, er spielt, glaube ich, darauf an, dass er immer die Enten Spezies und die Schwan halt nochmal lateinisch übersetzt hat, so im Sinne von er zeigt jetzt, ah, ich spreche auch Latein. Im Sinne von, ah ja. Und übersetzt jetzt mal Studium und zeigt dir, dass das eben kein sinnentleertes Lustwandeln. Im Sinne von, ich bin nicht einfach irgendein Service-Mitarbeiter, der bei Asty, Johnson und Sun wahrscheinlich nicht die Karriere machen wird, die er sich vorgestellt hat. Nein, er hat wirklich gezeigt, er kann auch Latein, er weiß, was er spricht. Ist das eine Anspielung auf irgendwas, sinnentleertes Lustwandeln? Fallen wir gerade jetzt auf irgendeine Trollerei von Ihrer Seite wieder aus rein? Oh, ich habe die auch einen Podcast. Das kann sein. Hört alle mal den WC-Ente-Podcast rein, um gucken, ob wir da vielleicht Thema sind. Aber krasse Antworten. Ob wir die ganze Zeit Mails von denen bekommen. Studium heißt Eifriges Lernen, sinnentleertes Lustwandeln. Das klingt als, aber ist das ein Thing, sinnentleertes Lustwandeln? Sagt man das oder ist es ein Neologismus von ihm? Ich bin mir gerade echt nicht sehr. Das erinnert mich an die Nachricht von unserem Direktor, als mal irgendwie zur Facharbeitsabgabe. Da treffen sich ja alle Schüler nochmal und geben ihre Facharbeit ab im Gymnasium und dann wird auch gefeiert, ah, jetzt endlich hat man die Facharbeit los. Und bei unserer Schule ist diese Feier ein bisschen eskaliert. Und jemand ist irgendwie von so einem Schneeberg runtergefallen und hat sich am Bein verletzt und es gab Alkoholausartungen. Und dann kam vom Direktor am nächsten Tag ein Bosterbrief an alle Eltern des Jahrgangs. Ja. Im Sinne von, ja, irgendwie, da haben sich Leute daneben benommen. benommen und dann hat er die Formulierung war irgendwie mit einige angeheiterte Jugendliche wankten mit ihren Bierhumpen durch das Schulgelände. Und ich war so fasziniert von dem Begriff Bierhumpen, weil das einfach alles kaputt macht, weil er durch seine gestochene Formulierung wieder alles so ins Lächerliche gezogen hat und man sich einfach, ja, ihr Sohn oder ihre Tochter sind einfach mit Bierflaschen übers Schulgelände gezogen und haben irgendwie Minderige belästigt. Okay, das hat einen Effekt, aber sobald du mit Bierhumpen, habe ich irgendwie so eine laute und irgendwie so mittelalterliche Leute im Hintergrund, die so mit so Trinkschläuchen und Hörnern.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Wort. Humpen verwendet man nur für Methumpen. Und das ist auch, und dann, das ist dann gleich wieder so, wie wenn er sagt, sinnentleertes Lustwandeln. Das ist genau wie mein... Frohlockend. Frohlockend mit einer Laute über des Hofes. Einfach so unnötig. Tatsächlich hat mein Direktor Romane geschrieben für Kinder, unter anderem über einen kleinen Mönch. Einen kleinen Mönch. Und es kann sein, dass er sich wegen seiner Schreibarbeit gerade in so einem mittelalterlichen Duktus bewegt hat und deswegen automatisch von Bierhumpen und den edlen Mägden geredet hat. Und plötzlich so ein Schweigegelübter erlassen wurde, dass niemand mehr reden durfte. Das kann sein. Naja, das fiel mir ein bisschen schlecht. Weil im Endeffekt, wo hat uns der ganze Spaß hingeführt? Wir reden hier zynisch drumrum die ganze Zeit. Moritz muss sich hier harte Worte gefallen lassen. Weißt du, und wir schicken dann, weil wir mal dachten, okay, jetzt wollen wir was verändern wirklich in der Welt, schicken die dann eine Mail und ziehen da aus ein paar Lacher. Wir haben gar nichts verändert. Wir haben nichts erreicht. Aber wir haben nichts verändert. Im Endeffekt sieht sie jetzt immer noch wie ein Schwan aus. Es gibt immer noch keine WC-Ente im klassischen Sinne des Wortes. WC-Schwan, das klingt nicht so schlecht. WC-Schwan. Schwan ist sogar das saubere Tier, weil die sind schön weiss, wohingegen Enten sind ekelhaft, die sind entweder braun oder irgendwie so komisch bunt.
Als Zeichen für Hygiene und Sauberkeit ist doch der Schwan, der weisse, reine Schwan viel besser.
Also auch Marketing-Denschen wird das viel mehr Sinn ergeben.
Ich weiß. Aber wie erzählen wir das hier? Die sind eher all unserer Meinung, aber trotzdem können wir nichts verändern.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass wir was verändern können. Denn wie erreicht man denn in der Marktwirtschaft was?
Durch Konkurrenzdruck. So, und deswegen starten wir eine Kickstarter-Kampagne für den WC-Schwan. Der WC-Schwan? Gleicher Inhalt, wir kaufen ganz viele WC-Enden, schneiden die Deckel ab, füllen das um in unsere selbst hergestellten WC-Schwan-Flaschen. Alles verboten. Wahrscheinlich müssen wir uns einen Chemiker holen, der uns ein ähnliches Produkt mischt. Aber Moment mal, also jetzt auch dieses WC-Schwan, WC-Enten-Mittel, das wird jetzt nicht so unendlich unterschiedlich sein von anderen Marktkonkurrenten. Ja, aber diese ganzen giftigen Kanister, diese Zyankali-Kanister, Blausäure will ich bei mir nicht lagern. Idee, wir nehmen einfach eine Packung WC-Ente und eine Packung, keine Ahnung, wie heissen die anderen, Fritt, nee, die, äh, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, eine Packung, keine Ahnung, wie heissen die anderen, Fritt, ne, Dr. Proper, und dann mischen wir das einfach 50-50. Dann ist es ein neues Produkt, da kann auch niemand sagen, Urheberrecht, weil letztlich sind die ganzen Stoffe, was ist da drin, halt dann irgendwie Chlor oder so. Kann man dann hinten auf der Zutatenliste, Ingredients, kann man dann schreiben, 50% Proper, 50% WC-Ente, aber dann muss man trotzdem Kaliumsulfat schreiben. Ja klar, da schreiben wir dann Kaliumsulfat, das Zeug, was hält. Kann man nicht schreiben, siehe WC-Ente? Nee, ich glaube, dann hast du wieder Urheberrechtsprobleme. Die wollen wir nicht. Weil wenn dann irgendwie so ein Chemiker kommt und das analysiert, sagt er, ja gut, diese chemische Zusammensetzung gibt's so noch nicht. Weißt du, was du sagst? Urheberrechtsprobleme, Schmurheberrechtsprobleme. Ist das wirklich ein Anwalt? Und, ähm, The Staircase, was ich immer noch sehr empfehlen wollte. Ja, vierte Woche in Folge Empfehlung von Stefan Witzel. Weil, da ist nämlich die Schwägerin, die Schwester der Ermordeten ist unglaublich sauer auf auf den Verurteilten, Angeklagten und am Ende hält sie dann vor dem Gericht, liest sie einen Brief vor. Und der, am Ende wird er, sorry, dass ich das spoilern muss, aber da geht es auch die ganze Zeit um, er wird verurteilt und will dann am Ende sozusagen einen sogenannten Alford Plea sprechen. Ein Elfer-Plee ist, du sagst, damit es endlich vorbei ist, die ganze Scheiße, plädierst du auf schuldig, sagst aber, dass du nicht deine Schuld zugibst. Du sagst, du hast es nicht gemacht, plädierst aber auf schuldig, damit das Verfahren vorbei ist. Und er wollte aber nie zugeben, dass er schuldig ist vor Gericht. Du musst es aber halt im Sinne des Alford-Plees, kannst du es so machen, weil er irgendwie in Alford war der Präzedenzfall. Und seine Schwägerin hat dann vor Gericht ausgesagt und wollte noch mal dem Richter sagen, ich glaube aber, dass er schuldig ist, hat dann gesagt, hat dann so einen langen Brief vorgelesen und der hat geendet mit Alford Schmelford. Dann hat sie den Richter angeguckt und den Team angeguckt und gesagt, naja, ich glaube, dass er schuld ist und ist gegangen. Erfurt Schmelfort. Wow. Und sie hat diesen Brief geschrieben. Man sieht kurz, dass sie die Kamera draufschwenkt und der ist handschriftlich geschrieben. Die hat sich Mühe gegeben. Geil. Die hat nämlich an den Formulierungen gesessen. Die bestmögliche Pointe. Und ich denke mir, die kommt, irgendwann kommt sie auf die Idee, Erfurt Schmelfort, guckt hoch, grinst kurz, nickt bedächtig und schreibt auf Erfurt Schmelfort, Punkt, faltet den Brief zusammen und trägt den morgens vor. Mega gut. Ja, gute Idee. Das ist richtig gut. Aber ich glaube, das geht. Ich meine, muss man bei Kickstarter dann schon was haben? Nö, du kannst ja einfach nur eine Idee verkaufen und du machst einen Kickstarter. Wie viel wird das kosten, ein neues chemisches Produkt auf den Markt zu werfen? Ich weiß es nicht. 200 Euro? Ja, zwei, naja, nee, ich glaube schon ein bisschen mehr. Also wir müssen ja auch, zumindest müssen wir jemanden anstellen, der, aber da können wir irgendwie den Prädikanten fragen, dass er einfach mal von Supermarkt zu Supermarkt geht, um einfach dem zu sagen, wir haben ein neues Produkt. Ja. Das ist ein Alternativprodukt zu der WC-Ente. Rewe macht das ja häufig. Beim Rewe stehen oft Produkte, die noch nicht wirklich sozusagen in die Rotation der großen Läden eingelangt sind, sondern halt einfach neue Produkte. Wir müssen mal schauen. Wir informieren uns da, aber ihr könnt auf jeden Fall schon mal bei Kickstarter gucken, weil Flo und Tina gleich noch sich die Arbeit machen wird, um den WC-Schwan einzustellen. Wir müssen halt gucken, was die WC-Ente sich vielleicht für Patente geholt hat. Oder wenn die diese Formen patentieren lassen. Andere Flaschen haben das auch. Ja? Ja. Aber was macht dann den Schwan besonders? Der Schwan ist einfach nur ein Fingerzeig in Richtung WC-Ente. Mit dem Schwan kauft man die Wahrheit. Du kaufst sozusagen eine Botschaft. Ja. Du kaufst nicht notwendige... Sehr gut. Die Werbekampagne basiert auch nur auf Moral. Ja, genau. Nur auf, wir sind vielleicht nicht so gut. Nee, wir sind nicht so gut. Wir sind schon besser. Nee, ich würde sagen, wir sind nicht so gut. Also, wenn ihr saubere Toiletten wollt, nehmt die WC-Ente, so offen kann man ja sein. Wenn ihr die Wahrheit wollt, kauft den WC-Schwan. Ja, ja. It's toasted. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich hab Madman gesehen, wir kriegen das hin mit der Marketingkampagne. Ja, auf mir keine Gedanken. Nee, da mache ich überhaupt keine Sorgen. Das Problem ist halt, dass unsere Zielgruppe halt nicht viel, glaube ich, Geld investiert für Barthygiene. Ich glaube, das ist eher ein Ding, da kaufen eher andere Zielgruppen, geben da viel Geld aus. Selbst wenn wir alle unsere Hörer dazu überzeugen könnten, ihr gesamtes Budget für Barthygiene in den WC-Schwan zu stecken, haben wir am Ende 350 Euro. Wieso war eine Flasche 350 Euro kostet? Was stört dich denn noch an WC-Reinigungsmitteln? Kann man nicht noch irgendwie noch mehr Innovationen vorantreiben? Ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden mit der Reinigung meines WCs, muss ich sagen. Aber wenn Sie jetzt sagen können, Sie können eine Sache, also wirklich mal träumen, traumhaft, wie würde für Sie die perfekte Badreinigungsflasche aussehen? Wirklich fantasiefreien Lauf gelassen. Ich finde schon, dass man beim WC endet, bei der WC hat eigentlich keine Wünsche offen bleiben, weil die genau runterpassen. Machen Sie mal keine Sorgen über Budget oder über Urheberrecht oder über Patente, sondern einfach mal träumen, das wäre perfekt. Wie würden Sie sich das vorstellen? Ich würde sagen, es könnte besser riechen, aber es riecht halt auch schon sehr, sehr gut. Also manchmal mache ich die Flasche noch auf, um daran zu riechen, weil es so gut riecht. Und wenn das jetzt irgendwie, angenommen, man würde die Öffnung jetzt so designen, dass sie so ein bisschen ist wie eine Pfeife. Das immer, wenn Sie draufdrücken und das Mittel kommt raus, dass es dann so wie so ein Schwan so macht.
Das wäre doch witzig für die Kinder. Ja, für die Kinder wäre es witzig, aber für sie wäre es nicht witzig. Da hat übrigens ein Hörer die beste Idee gehabt, WC-Enton für Kinder. Yes, aber dann sind wir wieder bei der Ente, wir wollen auch weg von der Ente, fuck, warum gibt es kein Schwan-Pokémon? Wir können doch eine WC-Enton machen.
Ja, da haben wir gleich zwei Urheberichtsprobleme, mit Nintendo und mit der WC-Ente.
Das ist nicht geholfen. Minus mal minus, er gibt Plus. Genau, soll die sich doch verklagen. Soll die sich verklagen. Aber der WC-Enton, aber jetzt brauchen wir ein neues Flaschendesign, weil jetzt muss der Hals halt, weil Enton hat keinen Hals. Enton hat keinen Hals, sondern so einen langen, breiten Schnabel. Ist kein gutes Produkt, aber Kinder werden langsam an Barthygiene gewöhnt. Das ist doch auch irgendwie die Idee. Also, bald im Handel, WC Anton, aber auch heute erstmal die Kickstarter-Kampagne für unsere neue Aktion WC Schwan. Vor allem, stell dir mal vor, also jetzt war letztens Tag des Emojis, haben wir komplett verpasst, unsere Emoji-Pitches liegen auch noch. Tag des Ufo verpasst, Tag des Emojis verpasst, Tag des Podcasts, dein Geburtstag. Sogar den Podcast-Ufo-Tag ist komplett an uns vorbeigelaufen. Und ich habe letztens gedacht, Emoji, irgendwann wird es doch anfangen, dass die anfangen, Lizenzen zu kaufen. Ja, ja. Dass man wirklich dann den Pikachu-Emoji hat. Und die ersten Firmen, die da einsteigen werden, die werden es ja machen.
Weil irgendwann nach zwei Jahren kommen dann,
oh, jetzt gibt es auch die Power Ranger-Emojis und die Scooby-Doo-Emojis.
Aber die werden sich dann, glaube ich, nicht mehr so durchsetzen.
Ich glaube, wenn jetzt wirklich Nintendo sagt, pass auf, Emoji, keine Ahnung, Apple,
gebt uns zehn Millionen Dollar, da habe ich noch sehr wenig,
und ihr könnt den Pikachu-Emoji haben. Zehn Millionen, dafür, dass die einfach sagen, ja, hier habt ihr hier diese Pixel-Grafik. Das würden die doch machen. Und Apple, also Apple hat ja keine Konkurrenzsituation mit Nintendo, die graben sich ja kein Wasser ab. Die haben ja auch keine Probleme mit, einfach das Pikachu-Emoji zu verwenden. Und dann, dann glaube ich, wäre das ein großer Erfolg. Der Pikachu-Emoji? Ich frage mich, ja. Wenn du so ein Simpsons-Emoji hast oder sowas? Ich glaube, die Ersten, die das machen, das sind die, die richtig Cash machen. Ich glaube, ich bleibe trotzdem bei Pokerchip. Der Pokerchip, glaube ich, und man muss sagen, es sind wieder 150 Emojis zugekommen jetzt. Ja, wo war der Pokerchip? Wo war der Pokerchip? Pokerchip, Mensch, der zur Tür rausgeht, Mensch, der sich versteckt. Nein, es gibt sowohl eine Tür als auch ein Mensch, der geht.
Man kriegt so lange ausgehen.
Nicht beides zusammen ein.
Es gibt kein Emoji,
der in irgendeiner Weise
sowas kommuniziert wie
Ich verstecke mich. Ja, es gibt einen Affen,
der sich die Augen zuhält. Klar.
Für peinliche Situationen.
Aber was ist denn mit einem Emoji,
wo man nur die obere Kopfhälfte sieht
und die andere ist hinter einem Stein?
Das ist doch gut, so heimlich, verstecklich.
Hinter Steinversteck im Moment.
Ja, oder hinter Steinversteck oder hinter der Ecke.
Dass man einmal die obere Hemisphäre
und einmal die westliche Hemisphäre des Kopfhälfs hat.
Wann sind die animiert?
Wann kommt der Moment, wo die animiert werden?
Nee, das glaube ich für den Moment. Ich glaube, der kommt. Nee, nee, nee, das ist ja gerade der Vorteil, dass es so ein Low-Kieze. Okay, das müssen wir auch mal machen, dringend vorbereiten. Ja, die Pitches für die... Ja, sorry, dass wir nicht so gut vorbereitet sind. Wir müssen... Wir haben halt auch noch ein Leben neben dem Podcast. Zum Beispiel haben wir natürlich in der letzten Zeit wahnsinnig viel Zeit damit verbracht, unsere Tour zu planen! Leute, es ist so ... Jesus, das kannst du nicht machen, da sind jetzt zu viel Leute aufgewacht. Hey, alle Leute, die jeweils wach sind, hey, wenn ihr jetzt schon keinen Bock mehr aufs Podcast-Ufo habt, weil ihr wütend seid, dass wir euch geweckt haben. Greift zu! Die Daten sind da, die Locations sind da, es wird eine zweite das Podcast-Ufo-Tour geben, offiziell, alles ist da, die Tickets sind verfügbar, soweit ich weiß, es gibt noch ein paar. Bis vorne auf die Grösse gibt es später auch noch kostenlos als Podcast-Tour. Und zwar, hier sind nochmal die Daten für euch alle. Leute, da ist für jeden was dabei. Am 23.09. sind wir in Mannheim. Mannheim. Am 10.10. sind wir in Hannover. Hannover. Am 19.11. sind wir in Hamburg. Hamburg, wo seid ihr? Am 10.12. sind wir in Köln am Tanzbrun. Geil. Da freuen wir uns sehr auf euch. Am 16.1. sind wir in Berlin. Am 26.2. sind wir in Wien, am 20.3. in Essen, am 7.4. in Leipzig und am 8.5. in München der grosse Tourabschluss. Ey, da wird's, es gibt für jeden auf jeden Fall was dabei. Kommt auf jeden Fall rum. Sogar für die Österreicher Wien habe ich mega Bock drauf, nach Wien zu fahren. Wir machen einen schönen Urlaub, wir schauen uns die Stadt ein bisschen an, machen eine geile Show. Das wird grossartig. Das wird richtig grossartig. Das glaube ich auch, das freut mich. Leute, greift zu, es gibt noch ein paar Tickets und Informationen findet ihr alle auf unserer Website oder auf Facebook, Twitter. Ja, eher auf Facebook. Eher auf Facebook, ja, ist gut. Ja, genau. Aber ich freue mich sehr drauf, ich bin sehr gespannt. Vielleicht haben wir da auch schon den ersten Schnitt von unserem Film, wer weiß. Vielleicht kriegen wir den nachgedreht. Den ersten Rohschnitt. Vielleicht können wir es so machen, dass wir vielleicht Leute finden, die immer eine Minute drehen. Ja. Also, dass Tom Tücker dreht die erste Minute, irgendwie ... Wes Anderson die zweite. Wes Anderson die zweite und dann haben wir so ganz viele Stile in einem Film vereint. Das wäre eigentlich ganz geil. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ist halt super verwirrend. Super nervig auch. Und weil es auch immer andere Schauspieler dann sein müssen. Also ultra nervig. Ultra furchtbar, auch teuer. Schrecklich, unglaublich teuer. Aber sowas gab es noch nie, das zieht bestimmt Leute ins Kino. Ja. Genau wie der Rembrandt-Film, der kommt doch jetzt auch bald. Der gemalte, der Van Gogh-Film. Ja, genau. Wo jeder einzelne Frame ein gemaltes Bild ist. Im Stile von Van Gogh gemaltes Bild ist. Und von, glaube ich, unterschiedlichen Leuten. Das heißt, es flackert dann halt so ein bisschen. Aber an sich ist es, glaube ich, eine ganz coole Idee. Und es wird beworben mit der schönste Film aller Zeiten. Sorry. Ganz kurz. Das ist schon hart. Der schönste Film. Vor allem ist das Wort schön auch jetzt nicht gerade wirklich präzise. Schön im Sinne von gut aussehend. Schön im Sinne von schöne Story, weiß man nicht genau. Ja, vor allem es klingt ja so ein bisschen wie so ein Kommentar, so, ah, ich mag euren Sketchkanal, sieht echt gut aus, gut produziert. Ja. So, das willst du nicht hören, vor allem nicht, wenn du dafür schreibst, weil damit hast du nichts zu tun und genauso willst du eigentlich noch nicht hören, der schönste, das ist genauso wie der beste Film zum Einschlafen. Der beste Podcast zum Einschlafen. Ich höre euch so gerne zum Einschlafen. Ja, danke, aber es ist nicht wirklich ein direktes Kompliment. Und wie gesagt, ich fahre jetzt in den Urlaub, aber nicht lange, nur eine Woche. Und danach geht es direkt weiter. Ich fahre schön an See. Ihr merkt ja auch, wir brauchen mal ein bisschen eine Pause. Wir müssen mal wieder Sachen erleben. Wir haben so viele Projekte jetzt am Start. Und erleben mal was Lustiges. Also, ja, ich gebe mir Mühe. Ich gebe mir Mühe. Also, mit offenen Armen, empfang die Gags mit offenen Armen. Ich lege mich in die Sonne. Empfang die unangenehmen Situationen. Red mal mit Fremden. Komm mal raus und ich will, dass du Gags mitbringst. Ich habe letztens, da bin ich durch die Gegend gelaufen mit T-Shirt und es war sonnig. Und ich dachte mir so. Jetzt das T-Shirt ausziehen. Jetzt, naja, weil man denkt sich dann, okay, jetztäune ich man denkt sich aber auch jede sekunde die ich bräune in der situation in denen körper teil meines körper bedeckt ist ja eigentlich schlecht weil dann hast du ja immer diese flecken die du nicht willst und dachte mir so die bikini spuren soll ich jetzt so die die ärmel von meinem t-shirt so hochkrempeln dass man die schulter sieht das ist aber dann denken wir laufe ich dir die Gegend wie so ein typ wie so ein Typ, der nichts zur Schau zu stellen hat, aber trotzdem was zur Schau stellt, dann sitzt du da mit deinen Schlotterarmen. Ja gut, aber deine Beine, das ist völlig egal. Ja, aber das zeigst du ja auch. Ja, aber gut. Du zeigst sehr auffällig viel Knöchel auch. Ja. Knöchel und auch sehr viel Oberschenkel noch. Das stimmt. Naja, dieses Tanktop-Bewusstsein habe ich auch nicht. Ich wünschte, ich hätte es manchmal ganz gern. Aber da muss man was in die Arme investieren. Also an Sport, Muskelmasse. Ich mache nächste Woche eine Safttherapie. Drei Tage lang trinke ich nur Saft. Das hast du schon mal gemacht. Nee, habe ich noch nie gemacht. Nee, Katja Anna hat das mal noch, glaube ich. Katja hat das mal gemacht, ein anderer Kollege hat das mal gemacht. Aber einfach mal drei Tage lang trinkst du dann alle zwei Stunden, kriegst du einen Saft. Und und dann quasi Detox-mäßig spürst du immer deinen Körper durch, weil nach drei Tagen hast du nichts mehr von allen anderen Sachen, die du vorher gegessen hast in deinem Körper. Ja, aber hast du das nicht normalerweise auch? Hm? Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie schlechtes Essen isst, dann isst das ja nach drei Tagen auch von deinem Haus. Ja, ja, aber du isst ja währenddessen schlechtes Essen. Also ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich hau mir abends dann auch was rein, wo ich mir denke, es ist nicht so richtig gut für den Körper. Die Reese's Puffs zum Beispiel, die ich mir jetzt gekauft habe. Okay. Die sind ja nicht gut für den Körper. Aber da trinkst du doch durch. Du bist ja nicht satt von Saft, oder? Ja, du trinkst ja alle zwei Stunden. Du hast ja quasi was, auf was du dich freuen kannst in den nächsten zwei Stunden, wenn dann der rote Beete-Saf kommt. Stefan, das wird schrecklich. Ich weiß nicht, ob du von dieser Schlaftechnik gehört hast, dass man sich langsam aber sicher den Schlaf abgewöhnt und so verlegt, dass man, glaube ich, alle zwei Stunden schläft man 20 Minuten. Das geht, glaube ich, nicht. Doch, das geht. Ja, ich glaube nicht, weil du brauchst eine langanhaltende REM-Schlafphasen. Ja, aber ist irgendwie so. Du kannst doch keinen Schlaf nachholen. Du kannst nicht. Also es gibt diese Technik, es gibt manche Leute, die das machen, das ist anscheinend brutal schwer, in diesen Rhythmus reinzukommen. Ja, nach drei Jahren sind die einfach durch. Aber wenn du dann irgendwie nach ein paar Monaten drin bist, hast du halt viel mehr vom Tag. Halt zu Zeiten, wo sonst niemand wach ist und es ist halt unerträglich sozial, weil du kannst ja nicht alle zwei Stunden, zwanzig Minuten schlafen, findet man einen Job so. Aber es gibt Leute, die das durchziehen und damit auch ganz gut fahren. Ich glaub, ich hab herausgefunden, warum man nachts zockt. Also warum ... Also wenn du dir einen Nerd vorstellst, der mal wieder irgendwie vor Dota sitzt oder so was, dann stellst du dir den eigentlich nachts vor, find ich. Also Zocker vermindest du häufig mit nachts. Und ich glaube, es liegt daran, wenn man nachts das Gefühl hat, man verplempert gerade nicht seine Zeit. Und man würde gerade sowieso nichts anderes machen. Ja, das stimmt. Was natürlich ein totaler Trugschluss ist, weil du halt den Schlaf ja nachholst wahrscheinlich und dann am nächsten Tag bis 13, 14 Uhr schläfst. Es stimmt aber schon, Schlaf kann man am einfachsten opfern, weil man sich denkt, man ist ja am nächsten Tag wieder mit allen gleich. Ja. Weil wenn du um acht Uhr in der Schule bist, hast du ja wieder einen fresh start sozusagen. Und ob du jetzt vier Stunden oder acht Stunden geschlafen hast, ist dann vergessen. Deswegen reise ich auch lieber dann immer nachts, weil ich denke, jetzt würde ich eh nichts anderes machen, was relativ produktiv ist. Wohingegen, wenn ich am nächsten Tag im Hotel schlafe und dann morgens nach Hause fahre wieder, dann ist das, dann fällt ja genau in meine produktive Zeit rein. Das ist gefährlich. Das ist mein Lebenstipp.
Ich hatte tatsächlich mal in meiner Hardcore World of Warcraft
Phase, ich glaube, es waren
zwei Nächte insgesamt,
wo man einfach dann zockt und dann irgendwie
zehn Uhr, elf Uhr, zwölf Uhr, ein Uhr
und denkt, muss ich langsam ins Bett gehen?
Und dann denkt man sich irgendwann, ja, oder
ich gehe einfach nicht ins Bett.
Jetzt ist auch egal. Ich zock einfach die Nacht durch.
Dann zockt man die Nacht durch. Um fünf Uhr denkt man dann, okay, das war eine richtig schlechte Idee, weil du fucking müde bist. Geh ich jetzt ins Bett. Aber dann denkt man sich, ob ich jetzt noch zwei Stunden schlafe, bringen auch nichts. Zockst du halt noch durch und hast einfach die ganze Nacht gezockt. Und das habe ich ein paar Mal gemacht, weil es ist wirklich so ein es ist wie ein Terminabsagen, was ja das schönste Gefühl ist der Welt, wie wir wissen. Und genauso ist es den Schlaf abzusagen. Du denkst dir so, nee, ich muss eigentlich nicht schlafen.
Und dann plötzlich denkst du, ich habe
plötzlich acht Stunden Zeit gewonnen
und ich kann zocken und ich gehe noch mal schön
Schwarzfels und so und das ist einfach geil.
Ich meine, das bereut sich innerhalb
von kürzester Zeit. Ist das ein Freizeitpark
bei WBW? Ja, einfach kannst du eine Balance
kaufen. Terminabsagen ist das schönste Gefühl der Welt,
es sei denn, du willst zu dem Termin.
Zu welchem Termin willst du denn wirklich? Na ja, so ein schönes Date. Nee, gerade ich glaube, Dates absagen ist das schönste Gefühl der Welt, es sei denn, du willst zu dem Termin. Zu welchem Termin willst du denn wirklich? So ein schönes Date? Nee, gerade ich glaube, Dates absagen ist die größte Erleichterung, weil da bist du ja total aufgeregt. So einen schönen Stand-Up-Auftritt? Glaube ich nicht, dass die Beispiele in die richtige Richtung gehen. So einen schönen Arzttermin? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man Lebenszips von dir so umsetzen sollte direkt. Was machst du denn? Du hast es in der Woche sturmfrei? Keine Podcast-Ufraufnahme? Hau mal ein paar lustige Tweets raus. Ich bin nur am Arbeiten und deswegen tut es mir leid, dass ich auch gar nicht so viele lustige Storys am Start habe. Ich habe die letzten zwei Wochen nur geschrieben in meiner Sturmkammerlein und ich bin auch total blass. Ich habe mittlerweile wie so ein Fisch, der in der Tiefsee lebt, so eine ungesunde, durchsichtige Haut.
Man kann durch mich durchgucken.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe jetzt irgendwie
nicht nur, weil ich in den Newsroom geguckt habe,
ich habe auch so, weil ich so viel Stress hatte,
habe ich echt überlegt, angefangen zu rauchen.
Ich habe wirklich überlegt, angefangen zu rauchen.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass du so da sitzt und der wirklich,
wie so eine Anschaffung. Doch!
Soll ich mir ein Boot kaufen und sage, soll ich jetzt anfangen zu rauchen?
Ohne Scheiss, es ist so irrational.
Aber ich dachte mir gestern, ich fange jetzt einfach an zu rauchen. Warum nicht? Das würde so nicht zu dir passen. Aber das ist doch genau die Idee. Das würde, wenn du zunächst morgen eine Lederjacke anhaben würdest, das würde niemand glauben. Die Leute würden wahrscheinlich denken, du würdest jetzt irgendwie so eine Kaugummi-Zigarette oder so ein Vape-Ding. Die Leute würden wahrscheinlich nicht mal glauben, dass du rauchst. Ich weiß nicht, es ist so viel Stress und dann denkt man, man braucht einfach mal eine Auszeit. Ich will einfach mehr Ausreden haben, mal kurz rauszugehen. Ja, aber dann stehst du draußen mit den Rauchern, musst mit den Orkut Gespräche führen und dann wirst du sofort wieder aufhören zu rauchen. Ich glaube auch, weil man dann, ich glaube, das ist auch, so würde ich mich das auch abtrainieren. Indem ich rausgehe zu rauchern und dann merke ich, ich glaube, die akzeptieren mich auch sozial nicht, weil die haben, seitdem sie acht Jahre lang sind, abends geraucht, nach draußen geraucht und haben mit Leuten gesprochen. Ich habe das ja nicht trainiert. Die haben die Themen. Was reden Raucher draussen? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Bei mir finde es absurd, dass ich... Meine schmeckt gerade richtig gut. So reden, was reden wir? Ah, der Zug tat gut. Riecht auch gut. Noch drei Züge, dann bin ich fertig. Das macht man nicht schnell. Ich glaube, in 20 Minuten rauche ich mir die nächste. Schön reinrauchen. Ich weiß noch, ich habe einmal, und das ist wirklich so ein Wunder, das geschehen ist. Ich habe Counter-Strike gespielt bei einem Freund von mir, der viel Counter-Strike gespielt hat. Ich habe nie Counter-Strike gespielt, nur einmal, als ich bei ihm war.
Anscheinend war irgendeine Version, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist, dass wenn du in den Chat schreibst, siehst du nicht, was du gerade schreibst, sondern du schreibst Enter, L-O-L, Enter und dann erscheint LOL. Du hast aber nicht dieses Chatfenster, wo du siehst, was du gerade schreibst oder ich wusste nur nicht, wo man es sieht oder so. Und dann hat jemandnung habe gerade stress mit meinen eltern und ich wollte halt bornten und dachte mir ich schreibe ich auch und durch ein absolutes wunder will ich ich auch eintippen und verschreibe
mich so dass ich schreibe ich rauche und das war so so ein eine erkenntnis für mich weil es auch so geil passt, dass jemand, so ein Jugendlicher, der halt Counter-Strike spielt, der dann schreibt, ich rauche. So ungefragt einfach, ich rauche. Und genauso stelle ich mir dich vor, wenn du rauchst, dass du konstant, dass du immer so wirklich deine Zigarettenpackung auch immer so in die Mitte des Zischens kriegst. Und immer so, kommt jemand raus für eine Fluppe? Einfach konstant erwähnen. Wie sagt ihr? Flippe? Oh, ein Flapsack war ich jetzt schön. Aber es klang so ein bisschen so, als wäre das dein Tipp, was man machen sollte, wenn man sich mit den Eltern streitet. Also ich rauche dann. Weil der andere Spieler schreibt, er will gerade Stress mit meinen Eltern. Ich rauche. Ich rauche. Wahrscheinlich habe ich da irgendeinen verlorenen 13-jährigen Jungen dazu animiert, anzufangen zu rauchen. Ich fange nicht an zu... such dir irgendwas anderes. Ich wüsste sogar schon, was ich rauche. Ja, Rothändler? American Spirit oder Rothändler rauchen. Ich habe mir schon so zurechtgelegt im Kopf. Natürlich mache ich das nicht. Solltet ihr auch nicht. Nicht rauchen, das ist doof, das ist dusselig, aber auch ganz cool. Such doch irgendwas anderes, such dir so eine Münze, die du immer so zwischen den Fingern her jonglierst. Oh, Zahnstocher. Ja, oder ein Zahnstocher. Strohhalm. Oder halt, trag immer Bowlingschuhe oder so. Es gibt so viele coole Sachen, wo dir einen schönen USP zu dir passt. Ich sehe mich ums USP, es geht mir darum, einfach mal runterzukommen. Aber dafür haben wir jetzt zwei Wochen Urlaub.
Nimm Bad.
Rauchen im Bad.
Okay, Leute, macht's gut, ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, genießt.
Ne, zwei schöne Wochen.
Genießt den Tag und wir hauen ein paar Links raus zu unser Kickstarter-Projekt.
Genau.
Und zu den Tickets, da könnt ihr euch noch welche holen.
Ich hoffe, es sind noch ein paar da.
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine fantastische Woche, haut rein.
Viel Spaß, bis in zwei Wochen.
Macht's gut, bis dahin. Ciao und wir heben ab.